hello there reject nation we are going
to watch today from spider war who just
went to the venom let there be carnage
premiere we weren't even fighting again
i want to see them
but today we're going to watch this
video that he put out yesterday called
spiderman no way home new fight scene
details venom 2 spiderman crossover
subscribe to spider warren if you
haven't done so already he gets to go to
things in la
that we don't get invited to when he
doesn't even live in l.a
thanks bud
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu right
now i'm actually on my way to see the
premiere for venom let there be carnage
okay it would be appropriate that i
would talk about venom yeah of course
recording this on an airplane today we
have details on a new scene from
spiderman no way home some of you may
have heard about this yesterday but i
can personally tell you that it fits
into a real plot leak which i am going
to talk about today you've probably
heard me talk about this plot leak that
has been proven to be real this scene is
actually a part of this and in this
video i'm going to be connecting the two
together then i'm going to talk about
the spider-man universe as a whole and
talk about how it's expanding how a new
movie for the spider-verse is going to
be coming out soon and how spider-man
will most likely be in that film as well
and not to mention it does look like the
venom universe and the mcu it could be
one they could actually be the same
universe and apparently we're going to
figure that out and venom let there be
carnage so this scene is actually a very
particular scene from the actual
official trailer that we got the scene
is where peter and doctor strange are
seemingly fighting each other we all
know gotcha gotcha yeah yeah and doctor
strange are on the train strange
multiplies the train and peter looks
around kind of in shock now in the
trailer they seemingly begin to fight
when dr strange says the problem is
peter is trying to live a double life we
then see strange kind of knock the
astral projection of peter out of his
body kind of knocks his soul out of his
body and the reason that he seemingly
does this is because of what is in his
hand if you look closely at the left
hand of spider-man you can see that
peter parker is holding some type of
artifact it seems to be in the shape
since the body does seem to be very
important important enough for peter to
try and take and strange to go after him
for now this report of this scene is
coming from the
cosmiccircus.com and this is what they
have to say about this cube artifact
let's hear it the cube's nature is
actually original to the mcu and not
something that has been seen in marvel
comics before however they go on to say
but more on that another time not giving
any more details about the cube
fortunately i do know a little more
about the cube which i'll talk about in
a bit but let's finish this scene first
the cosmic circus goes on to say that
they have exclusively learned that
during this chase sequence there will be
a point when stephen will actually use
the cloak of levitation to try and trap
spider-man during this chase and again
more on the chase and just a bit
integrated suit
by technicality peter will don strange's
iconic cloak at one point during the
chase sequence much like we saw his
counterpart and what if however instead
of the cloak teaming up with spider-man
like it did in what if it's actually
going to be going against him and still
going to be strangers since strange is
alive and not a zombie
waiting for use this to hold peter in
place and bring him back to him in order
to confront him directly so that'll be a
cool scene to see we kind of saw the
club fight on its own during what if but
now we're going to see it happen live
action against spider-man i actually
love the idea of just seeing that on a
live action screen i think when we saw
that image on what if we wanted to see
something like that in the live action
format to know that we're going to be
getting even just a hint of it
come on just how cool is that you just
know it's like it's cool it's cool bring
it to life i wonder if at any point he
will be using the cape the cloak of
levitation though to aid him in a fight
versus the the cloak just being used
against him at one point now that would
be fascinating to see if you were upset
about how much tech he gets from iron
man just imagine
all the magic gear he gets my doctors
exactly it's gonna be awesome now as far
as the cube is concerned and as far as
the so-called chase is concerned here's
what we know the plot leak says that the
spell goes wrong and we do hear doctor
strange telling peter that he is
tampering with the spell as he's doing
it in the trailer so the spell goes
wrong and it ends up bringing five
spider villains from other dimensions to
the mcu of course we know which ones
they are but basically they're being
kept in some sort of a magical prison
that doctor strange is holding them in
doctor strange wants to send them back
to where they came from however the
villains argue that if they do that they
are just going to die they're going to
go back to that same exact point where
they died and die so peter doesn't want
to send them back because he feels bad
that another spider-man kills them and
here's where things get important oh
okay so is the cube is that where peter
went
in that photo that was circulating the
internet that had the models of lizard
and sandman so he's in the queue is that
where that's whole sequence takes place
oh
cool
yeah why is he wearing a suit when he's
in there because he wanted to respect
all of that i'm gonna go in this cube i
better dress up yeah i better impress
anybody who might be lurking inside
why why his voice sounds like that it
says that norman osborne manipulates
peter parker into releasing the villains
and from here peter fights strange and
breaks the key which is a cube that held
them captive and the villains are now
free so this scene that we are
apparently going to be seeing right here
is this scene i wish it was the cube
from cube that astral projection knock
where peter is holding the cube is most
likely this scene now it does say that
when the villains break out they start
to terrorize new york and one would
think that if they got loose in the
sanctum strange could have some type of
procedure or measurements in place for
defensive procedures to stop them
somehow from getting outside of the
sanctum however since the key is
apparently what is holding the villains
captive it is a possibility that they
could actually be inside of that cube
because they are outside in this scene
and if the cube breaks here and it's
holding them that could be how they get
released into new york we'll have to
wait and see but it does right now seem
like the key is some sort of a prison or
the key to a prison and it seemingly is
going to be an mcu proprietary artifact
so i am very curious to learn more about
this can't wait to buy that toy
imprisonment first connects to venom
because according to some recent reports
the venom sony universe and the
spider-man mcu universe are the same
they're not different now this is kind
of contradictory to what we knew in the
past but keep in mind that sony did just
change their universe's name now it's
simply a sony spider-man universe why
the change right before spider-man way
home and venom let there be carnage come
out this has been expected for a while
but now it's getting a little bit more
real the closer we get to venom let
there be carnage and according to a
recent report from deadline on their
hero nation podcast they said two things
firstly venom is reportedly expected to
connect to the mcu version of spider-man
and secondly a new sinister six film is
apparently going to be off the ground
at least that is sony's goal that's
always their goal i have heard rumors
about this behind the scenes that i will
not go into to protect people but yes
that is a hundred percent
for sure that they are they're trying to
get an actual sinister six movie off the
ground i have no idea if it's gonna be
something that is like these villains
specifically or if their sinister six
will be more of the new variations like
crave the hunter morbius not mobius not
morpheus
mo
because he's morbid and dead yes morbius
and
uh you know like other characters
[Laughter]
so i don't know which ones they're going
to be going for specifically yeah that
is something that they're trying to get
off the ground again i don't think it's
going to be at all what the drew garga
one was attempting to be which
sucks because you got it would have been
perfect for it maybe john watts will
just do it you know do all the
spider-man films from now on now as far
as connecting venom to spider-man there
are rumors about a post-credit scene in
venom let there be carnage that does
exactly this connect venom to the mcu
that will obviously have to wait until
week against kevin
feige's sinister six film is concerned
we do know that they tried to make one
in the past before they had a director
planned and everything for it however it
didn't get made but recently back in
2019 spider-man franchise producer amy
pascal teased the eventual formation of
the sinister six telling us that all the
villains have actually been introduced
in the last two spider-man films
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home now since we are getting a
different sinister six in spider-man no
way home those plans could have changed
a little bit but it does still look like
an actual movie just focusing on the
sinister six is going to happen
eventually at some point in time which
makes us wonder are these villains going
to die in this universe are they going
to go free what exactly is going to
happen we'll have to wait till no way
home to find that out but this could
come as good news to some fans because a
lot of people want to see just one peter
parker tom holland's peter parker go up
against the sinister six okay here's my
concern about the sinister six thing
it's the same issue that you know a lot
of people and myself sort of share some
grips with venom about the idea of the
sinister six each individually have had
one-on-one encounters with spider-man he
is the only thing to foil what could
have been their greatest successful
villainous plan like that's the point of
the sinister six of why they form us
like we all share a common enemy and
that's spider-man
so we gotta take him out i feel like
we're gonna do a sinister six movie you
gotta build to that properly
and it seems like a big part of what
makes the dna of a lot of the members
that alternate within the sinister six
revolve towards their goal being take
out spider-man i don't get the vibe that
they're trying to do a sinister six
versus spider-man i get the vibe they're
just doing some like sinister like
almost like a suicide squad yeah exactly
which is uh the way they've set it up
now i'm like maybe they'll just do it in
reverse where none of the villains know
spider-man slowly they all meet him and
then he becomes the villain of the
entire universe and then we just follow
the villain characters as if they're
heroes and the sony spider-man universe
will truly be a menace what do you think
about the scene and are you excited for
the venomverse to finally connect to the
mcu let me know and don't forget to like
this video and of course for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
i mean i'm excited to see tom hardy and
tom holland cross i think the thing
though is is that what makes the venom
and spider-man uh dynamic work so well
is the fact that it's so personal
because both eddie brock and venom
hate
spider-man and partly because it they it
stems from loving spider-man it's one
thing spectacular spider-man captures so
well the prior relationship eddie brock
and peter have with each other it's a
little different than the comics but
having that there is a big part of what
makes
like the reasoning for venom hating
spider-man work so well why the fight
scenes and the action and everything
that progresses so engaging i just hope
that when they finally do cross somehow
they capture the spirit of that as
opposed to them just fighting each other
for some reason alright guys well leave
your thoughts down below why don't you
go ahead and subscribe hit that bell a
like button you know spider-man stuff
we'll catch you guys soon